i cannot make this [ __ ] story up this
is a true [ __ ] story i go into the to
the woman's bathroom right
and i don't know and the only reason why
i know this lady pulls down she goes
excuse me sir you are in the woman's
bathroom as i'm processing this like oh
[ __ ] i'm in the woman's bathroom yeah
this other lady walks up an asian woman
and she goes comes up and he goes
did you ask
what his or her pronouns are
bro in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast i decorated the
set it looks a lot better than it did
before and i did some [ __ ] work
we have ed park in the house once again
what's up yeah this place is nice so you
had to move to a new place yeah so in
the previous podcast it's funny because
i just got back from uh painting the
place yeah so just to update you on it
it was in the previous episode this lady
and you know i've been talking to the
neighbors about her and they all [ __ ]
hate her okay yeah so she apparently has
a history of just being an [ __ ] yeah
and so all the neighbors do not like her
and it's funny because one of the people
that we got really close to in the
neighborhood she was like can i come in
and see the house because i guess she
was telling people that she redid the
places so much better and then they this
uh one of the people that we got close
to the neighbor walked in she's like she
didn't do anything
this place is weird i was like yes it's
very weird in here it's like this weird
l-shaped house yeah with like no windows
in like the kitchen or anything exactly
she comes in and she's like um
what what is this with this huge
fireplace like it takes up the whole
living room i'm like i know
that is her pride and joy though dude
the
i think it was worse in your bedroom oh
my god the first time i checked out your
bedroom and that fireplace was half of
the wall was the whole wall yeah the
whole wall you're just like what the
[ __ ] it's the whole wall and then the
other wall is all closet yeah and then
there's the backyard door which by the
way the only way you can get to the
backyard is through your bedroom
it's like you're not gonna have a
barbecue back there dude this is gonna
move in and out exactly so this lady uh
she it's funny because the last thing i
emailed her i was like listen like we're
we're not agreeing upon anything and
this is not like civil discourse so you
could say everything that you said to me
in the email to my face yeah and so uh
she's like well i don't know if i'm
gonna be there i might say management
but she's actually here today i saw her
car and she was just avoiding me i'm
like listen
i'm
i'll tell you this there has never been
a single landlord that hated me
i've always gotten my full deposit back
that's how good of a [ __ ] tenant i am
just because i i know that if i owned a
home i would want them to take care of
it really really well yeah for sure yeah
to the point where i never even drilled
holes in the wall like i just did
everything with commanding but you also
couldn't because it was all concrete
exactly so
been in that place so many times he
knows how [ __ ] cold it is a dungeon
yeah and so
you know at the end of the day with this
lady like
she she basically wanted me to repaint
every wall the same color that it was
when she lived there which was six or
seven different colors before we left
and i'm like you never painted the place
for us when we came in we never got a
fresh coat of paint and what are you
talking about right now this is nonsense
are you supposed to know which swatches
and what color codes they are they just
said put it back and you don't even know
yeah we don't even know and so you know
i'm like no that's unreasonable because
i would paint give a fresh coat of paint
if i got a fresh coat of paint this
place was trash when we got in here and
so we repainted the place and so i met
her halfway which i didn't have to and i
repainted the the room baby blue which
was the original color
and then marielle's seafoam green and so
i'm like you know what i'm gonna meet
her halfway and i'm just gonna be kind
i'm gonna try my best but if she [ __ ]
test me i'm gonna bury her dude yeah i
mean i'm having trouble right now with
my landlord too
um
i posted it on my uh instagram stories
but i was featured on the last
um i'm going through what a lot of
people in l.a are going through and you
know it's about um
it's pretty much the the moratorium
right you can't raise the rent
yeah and especially in rent control
buildings yeah or anything so i'm having
that problem because they're using a
loophole
in the leasing contract and saying i'm
already getting a discount so i'm not
actually paying the rent price so this
isn't a rent
raise
it's a smaller discount
but i still have to pay more but it's
still a discount so it's an entire
loophole
i i know thousands of people around la
are going through is this applicable to
uh people who run out their homes is not
right it's just rent controlled areas
yeah like apartments yeah apartments i
mean just because of more time you can't
raise rent anyway you know wherever you
are i believe yeah well that's the
interesting thing too with this lady
like she tried to raise rent on us by
like six percent which is the california
maximum yeah and i basically wrote to
her i was like hey um it's pandemic
right now and she goes well because of
so this is what she did first which is
the most this is the this is the thing
that [ __ ] pissed me off so our year
contract was up and then she goes hey
are you guys planning to stay here again
i was like yeah we'll probably keep it
month to month but most likely we'll
stay here for a year yeah right we're
probably we're playing the place close
to three years yeah
she goes okay send us a contract and
we're about to sign it
but then she raised the rent by like 300
bucks didn't mention it and i'm like
what in the mario she goes hey are you
just i think the the rent number is like
300 higher she goes yeah well because
you know inflation and all this other
stuff um
i'm like
okay [ __ ] you can't just sneak it in on
us yeah i was like what the [ __ ] kind of
dirty [ __ ] [ __ ] is this yeah and she
said yeah we raised it by like six or
seven percent and i'm like that's like
the california maximum the the situation
you and i are in is just because of
[ __ ] greed it's not like you missed
any payments or you had complaints or
you were a bad tenant and so you know
what because i have to fix so much [ __ ]
i got to raise a rent on you
clearly you like they're just phrasing
it because they want more money exactly
and so like with this lady like the most
ridiculous thing that she did was number
one she tried to sneak that uh
the price raise in right which by the
way if she would have just told us like
listen like i got a lot of costs and
expenses and this is what this place is
going to cost we could have talked about
it yeah you know what i mean but the
fact that she did that and then on top
of that she goes i actually should be
charging you 4 500 bucks so she was
trying to make it seem like we should be
grateful that's what i'm saying with
this [ __ ] discount [ __ ] like i'm
already giving you a discount the
discount's just smaller like [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] you it's the most ridiculous
thing ever i was like why are you
talking to me like this like what the
[ __ ] did i ever do to you and so not
only did she raise her up and i
basically messaged her back i said hey
listen i asked all my friends who are
renting homes right now because of
pandemic none of them raised the rent
yeah i was like at most one of them
raised it by two percent highest i was
like you're going by the california
maximum that is i was like that is
extremely unfair you know what i mean
especially because her place is the
worst home in the whole neighborhood
i was like your home is [ __ ] it's
garbage the only reason why we rented
that place was because during the time
of pandemic everybody was renting homes
and hers was the only one available that
we could get yeah we didn't like it when
we walked in there we just said okay
this lady didn't paint the walls um oh
there's plant splatters everywhere and
she's not gonna fix it well fine [ __ ] it
we'll just rent it and now she's saying
like i gave you to this gave you this
place in perfect condition but we have
photos of how shitty it was
this is some [ __ ] foul [ __ ] i hate
that this is going on but that the crazy
thing is like you're not the only one
like everybody including me like i
couldn't even put holes in my wall
because they told me i couldn't and then
later like i was doing a zoom call with
a neighbor and they had like all this
[ __ ] posted on their walls like what the
[ __ ] they told us we couldn't like have
holes in the wall and then i see a dog
walking through like they told us we
couldn't have pets yeah i would have got
a dog a long time ago
it's the most ridiculous thing dude like
i listen i understand too like for
people who are landlords like i know in
california the law doesn't favor them in
certain aspects right yeah but when you
treat [ __ ] tenants who are just
paying rent yeah normally and you don't
miss payments yeah and in in this
pandemic epidemic like there's a lot of
people not paying rent so many people
and we're paying our [ __ ] rent
exactly raising it on us in lieu of what
other people who don't pay rent exactly
that's what i'm getting so pissed off
about this lady too is going to [ __ ]
hell and i can't wait to see her
tomorrow i'm just going to stare
directly in her beady little [ __ ] rat
eyes
i told her you have to say everything
you said in that email to my face like i
want you to you're [ __ ] brave over
email say that [ __ ] to my face yeah
i mean like you get a 70 year old lady
well you get to direct directly confront
them like uh my management there's a
management company who's a liaison
pretty much who deals with the all the
landlord [ __ ]
so it's like they they don't give a [ __ ]
either because they're just a third
party so i'm just stuck in this [ __ ]
too that's crazy man like people are
just getting taken advantage of it is so
[ __ ] obnoxious man and then on top of
that like having to deal with the move
and everything else and like cleaning up
this place or whatever it's like i had a
show out in pittsburgh and i literally
just wanted to say this story you read
the other podcast with him i'd even say
it on that on that podcast because this
is like one of the most
there are things that i do in my life
where i kind of just go why the [ __ ] did
you do that
you're so [ __ ] embarrassing i want to
beat your i want to beat my own ass
so
when i'm in the airport the first thing
that i do is i
once i go past tsa i put on my earbuds
well the thing is when i put on my
earbuds and i'm either listening to
music or a podcast i kind of zone out
and i don't really pay attention to
anything because i'm only looking for my
gate once i find my gate i know where it
is the fight is on time then i just go
do whatever and i have music in my ears
yeah well
this actually happened to me a couple of
times where i've walked into the woman's
restroom
they've got weird roundabouts all these
airports have [ __ ] up restrooms right
yes
dude i've walked into a woman's restroom
multiple times right and it's not on
purpose yeah so this time this is this
is just to show you how different times
are right yeah so
i cannot make this [ __ ] story up this
is a true [ __ ] story so i go into the
to the woman's bathroom right
and i don't know and the only reason why
i know this lady's talking but i have
music in my ear right and this lady
pulls down she goes excuse me sir you
are in the woman's bathroom and as she's
saying this i'm processing her i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm in the men's bathroom
but you know when when you kind of like
realize you [ __ ] up everything starts
to move slow and you can feel like the
gears turning your hairs get hot you're
looking around wait wait all stalls
as i'm processing this like oh [ __ ] i'm
in the woman's bathroom yeah this other
lady walks up an asian woman and she
goes comes up and he goes
did you ask
what his or her pronouns are
bro
i
i don't know what's i'm i'm still
processing this i'm sitting i'm standing
there and she goes did you ask what his
or her pronouns are
right and then she goes excuse me it was
like you don't know
bro i'm not i'm not [ __ ] lying and
i'm standing there just
what's going on you know and this lady
is vehemently
defending me
well she doesn't know i identify as a
male you're just [ __ ] up so she's
literally
getting in this lady's face going like
you didn't ask what his or her pronouns
are
[Laughter]
and i know i at this point i should say
something i should be like hey i'm
actually a man
i just [ __ ] up and i walked into the
wrong bathroom but my anxiety starts to
kick in right because i'm in this very
weird awkward situation and she goes you
know what she goes she looks at me she
goes
what do you identify with and she goes
and i i'm blank
i was like
you probably identify as a female that's
why you're in the women's bathroom right
and i went
yes
bro
as i'm [ __ ] saying this i just go
and i walk past them as these two are
arguing and i just go into a stall
so
[ __ ] embarrassed
because i caught the [ __ ] commotion
that i should i don't know why i said
yes i just walked into the stall and i
sat there
and i can hear them fighting and arguing
she goes this is [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] liberal bull and they're
screaming at each other and she goes you
need to let people live the life that
they want to [ __ ] live she's not
doing anything wrong and i'm sitting
here mortified
in this [ __ ] bathroom stall
and i'm so [ __ ] lucky because this
was like
this was like super early in the [ __ ]
morning this was in los angeles yeah
this is on the way to pittsburgh this
was like i don't know [ __ ] i forgot
what time it was but super early in the
[ __ ] morning
and i was just sitting in the [ __ ]
bathroom just mortified and i'm like
sitting there like
why didn't you do that david
why didn't you just say you were a
[ __ ] man a part of me didn't want to
say that because this lady was trying so
hard to defend me
[Laughter]
it's like who do i want to embarrass
more
the lady who's mad at me or the lady
who's defending me
and because it's so early in the morning
you guys hear just some yelling at each
other and then he goes [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this whole [ __ ] season i [ __ ] hate
los angeles you guys are a bunch of
[ __ ] libtards and then she just
starts storming out and then the other
lady she sat at the stall and she goes
are you okay
okay
and i'm like yeah yeah
yeah am i i'm like i'm like yeah thanks
i'm just gonna finish up and i'll be out
like thank you so much but as i'm saying
this i sound really nice but in the
[ __ ] bathroom i'm like gripping at my
shirt like
you're so stupid
he's like
what have i gotten myself into right but
i'm so [ __ ] lucky because it was so
early in the morning there was like
nobody at the airport yeah so like i
just had to wait until like it was
completely empty and i just grabbed my
[ __ ] i [ __ ] ran out and i just went
to the men's bathroom you just held it
it's like i can't even use it dog my
[ __ ] face is hot right now just
thinking about it imagine you just
started peeing there like it sounds like
a man's pee hey don't assume
don't assume that the sound of my
waterfall
is the sound of a male's waterfall
dawg that was one of the probably the
most mortifying experiences of my life
simply because i couldn't just say i'm a
man it's all good i walked into the
wrong bathroom because i wanted to be on
the side of the lady that defended me
yeah but you're in such shock like you
couldn't jump ahead and be like oh [ __ ]
and i've said this multiple times on the
podcast like we always say that we think
we know what we'll do in these dire
situations
don't no
you don't know when i first started
doing jk news years ago i was so
judgmental because i was very young yeah
this was like 10 years ago and i'm like
doc i would have never done that [ __ ] oh
i would have stepped and i would no i
wouldn't
apparently i'm a [ __ ] coward i had no
idea
i could not [ __ ] do it but you never
know like when your adrenaline's going
everything moves super [ __ ] slow yeah
i could literally feel the gears turn in
my head my ears get red my face turned
red and i just
i what i knew what i what i had to say
but i refused
you know
i think if you just left and went into
the men's room guess what they would
have fought
harder would have been throwing hands
see look what you did
it doesn't [ __ ] matter you didn't ask
his or her prone hey by the way i don't
know if uh asian lady if you ever see
this podcast video i am so sorry you
didn't have to do any of that stuff
thank you
but i identify as a [ __ ] male that's
that's the best part about being a
semi-famous not everyone recognizes you
i know oh bro this is literally one of
the worst things i've ever done in my
life i i i am
definitely ashamed i'm very very much
ashamed and this is like one of those
memories i just keep trying to bury but
i feel better now that i said it out
loud yeah but if you had i bet if you
had said oh i am a guy what do you think
that that asian lady would have said i
think she would have just doubled down
and been like it doesn't [ __ ] matter
it's about how you because you know i
bet she would have been caught in her
own [ __ ] all right she would have
just doubled like i did yeah
and i would have felt for her like i
would have done the same
dude
i don't know
i thought you were being saved but uh no
you just fell into
a really weird conundrum this is like
one of those like tv sitcom moments yeah
i i it was like i was in the episode of
seinfeld
it's like something that would have
happened to george costanza
you just you just have to go with it
like a part of me was like don't even
tell the story just write it into like a
tv show thing but it just happened it's
real life real life like this happens
it's so [ __ ] weird because this would
have never happened 10 years ago i
wonder how you were dressed i was just
like a dude just like i was in sweats
and a hoodie
oh you know what you might have been
butch
you didn't even thought you were
probably some butch lesbians in the
secret society hoodie sweats
and a cap
that's this is when you can blame blame
it on the guy for how he's dressed yeah
i know he sounds like a [ __ ] man but
look at those breasts
that is a
woman yeah
have you ever seen man titties like this
no these are full
very perky
honestly she could be breastfeeding
right now you wouldn't even know
oh okay that kind of makes sense oh my
god oh my god one of the worst
experiences of my life and i don't even
understand how the [ __ ] these things
happen to me like i don't get it because
every time somebody tells me like some
weird [ __ ] happens i'm like that's cool
let me tell you about my weird [ __ ]
you can't out weird the weirdo oh my god
my [ __ ] ears are hot dude because i'm
reliving the whole experience right now
oh my gosh at least it happened
it happened and you can talk about it
see that's another thing that i guess
people don't realize is that
um you've experienced some a lot of
shame
right and so your shame threshold is so
high that like when you have like haters
and [ __ ] trying to talk [ __ ] about you
say you're fat or whatever you're like
dude
you don't know the kind of situation
like you met kevin hart and kevin hart
just looked at your only fan photos
it's like do you think your haters like
being in that kind of embarrassing
situation do you think anything else is
that much more shameful to you
and you know what i always do is
whenever i go on tiger belly i just look
at bobby lee yeah i'm like
i'm not that bad dude yeah this guy
doesn't give a [ __ ] zero zero shame yeah
and i think sometimes too like a lot of
like comics and podcasters too they kind
of um they get a lot of flack because
when they get shat on they get hyper
defensive right right but if you just
kind of dive yourself into the
embarrassment and you're allowed to
laugh at it yeah then you're pretty much
good man that was part of louis ck's uh
new stand-up there was a whole bit where
he talks about such a situation i love
that dude that's awesome and look at
look at dave chappelle over the years as
he's constantly bringing up some of his
most embarrassing moments in his life
yeah he's being incredibly self-aware of
what he's going through but
part of the joke is like his hypocrisy
or how he deals with it too right and
even for you to have to go through this
to say it out loud but be able to laugh
at it is what like i guess that's the
comedian's heart right yeah yeah yeah
that's that's just what it is about it's
like talking about the [ __ ] that you've
been through right yeah
that's why earlier today i just told my
friends about the time i got uh my
prostate checked right oh my god what
was that what's that like bro wait you
haven't got it done yet no not yet dude
when you're 30 you're supposed to get
your prostate checked oh really that
that was a 40.
really why did people tell me 30.
[Laughter]
but uh
so when i turned 30 like i was big and
fat yeah i mean i was like you know what
i need to go see a doctor because i i
haven't done it before
and i saw
i saw a korean doctor in k-town
right
and he's like five foot six five five or
whatever he's he's
um really sweet kind of guys
he's asking me these questions because
i'm just doing a physical right and even
one of the questions was like are you
sexually active and i was like uh yes
and he goes do you use condom
and i said yes and then he goes oh good
it's a bad
and then he did the check up all this
[ __ ] he was like uh was your was your
father like you too like like me what oh
was he obese
it's like no
you could tell straight up right now
this is a korean doctor
has no
just no filters no filter no wherewithal
for people's feelings whatsoever so is
it your daddy also agreed
so i'm like no no just me and then um
towards the end like i thought it was
just about to get done and then he's
like um oh so do you get your prostate
checked and i'm like no okay we you have
to do it let's do it now because you're
30.
and i'm like oh all right and then he
goes over and then he starts putting the
glove on right i'm like wait how do you
check a prostate right hold on
what's the prostate yeah he's like he's
like oh ain't only ain't only so he's
already getting right he already has the
glove on he has lube in his hand he's
like
i like filling it up he's like yeah drop
your pants
right and i'm like like do i have to
he's like yes you're 30 you need your
prostate oh [ __ ] so i'm like okay i'm
thinking my head this medical this is
normal this is normal you know
so he's like drop your pants or whatever
so i drop my pants turn around and it's
just this [ __ ] cold ass finger in my
ass and i'm just like oh [ __ ] like i
don't it happens so fast yeah there's no
time to think that if this is sexual
assault or not yeah yeah you just have
like this is this is medical this is
medical this is for my health it's for
my health right
and then
as soon as it's over he goes he's like i
feel weird huh
yes and he goes hey
[Laughter]
he says
he's like oh you know it's not that bad
you know when i was when i was doing my
residency
my doctor
he's the six foot poor
giant white man right and his finger was
like the banana
and he put that in my butt he's like you
know my finger is not that bad sorry
all right
okay
can we wrap this up
i i mean it does make me feel better
because you got it worse than me
he's like so uh what are you doing after
do you like banana
you wanna like uh go hang out or
something
all that to say it was a crazy
experience but if you're a dude and
you're reaching 30 go get your prostate
checked dude i i didn't even know
i found out today because i was talking
to somebody who had like hemorrhoids and
apparently i had hemorrhoids when i was
super out of shape and fat oh really
[ __ ] blood oh [ __ ] right and it's just
because when you push really hard and
[ __ ] i'm just like
damn i think i just pushed too hard
but i just literally popped a vein in my
ass
and i was like oh because you'll tell me
what a hemorrhoid is i'm like yeah oh i
had that like multiple times all right
see like cause i was bad i would post
[ __ ] blood too yeah we wouldn't know
what the [ __ ] it like i thought it was
an ulcer or some [ __ ] and whatever it
was just you know
stretching out
[Laughter]
dude
you have [ __ ] up a little more banana
your doctor is so freaking weird dude
i i recently just got a um
i signed up for kaiser and i found out
my
it's always weird because i i signed up
for a uh general physician right and you
know i picked one out and i specifically
picked him out because he went to davis
medical school but from his photo on his
on his uh picture he looks like he's in
his 40s right and then when he came into
the room i looked at him and i was like
same face a lot younger i was like this
is going to be weird i bet you he's in
the same graduating class as my best
friend
and lo and [ __ ] behold dude he knows
your best friend yeah and i was like
yeah blah blah blah i was like because
i'm very thorough about finding doctors
and i specifically like doctors who went
to davis medical school because they
sent they seemed to have a better
bedside manner right um i've had
physicians who went to like stanford and
all these and they're very cold i don't
know [ __ ] why so when you go to
doctor's office you read their diplomas
i should start doing that
so before you pick a physician you could
see their bio and where they're from and
i see david and i look when i was like
so what year did you go to davis medical
school he goes how did you know that i
was like i do a lot of research before i
find
my my family doctor or my general
physician and he goes oh [ __ ]
i was like uh my best friend uh he went
to davis and he said who's your best
friend i was like gabo he goes i know
him
because this fool is like the mayor
right he's such a extrovert everybody
knows who the [ __ ] he is but at this
point too just like now i have to get a
physical by this guy you're in good
hands i guess we're [ __ ] best friends
now but no banana fingers yeah but then
he was like
dropping your pants
yeah
you have to yeah did you have you been
following kanye west
a little bit just because of like it's
just all over the news how he's [ __ ]
on pete davidson and [ __ ] it's crazy so
i mean it all started back when you know
people started i mean everybody knows
that he's i think he's clinically
bipolar or yes he is yeah he's
clinically bipolar right yeah so
it's weird when somebody looks at this
and they're kind of like i can't be gay
so stupid it's like no he's bipolar bro
like he's not he's nobody can stop him
yeah
he's like who are you going to stop
which which caught you yeah and so
it started with you know when uh kanye
and kim got divorced i remember there
was a very sweet story that i first
heard right before they got divorced
which i thought was really odd because a
story leaked i think i think kanye's the
one that told the story was on an
interview where
um
kim got a huge brand deal and i'm
guessing it was like seven figures right
for a company that basically jacked
kanye's designs
and then
she she asked kanye's like hey do you
would you
do you want me to do this brand deal or
not because i know that these people
clearly stole your designs right yeah
and he goes no i would not like that and
i think that's you know that's wrong so
she she goes got it and she didn't do
the brand deal it was like millions of
dollars yeah the next day
uh kanye came and he gave her a million
dollar check
and he gave her ownership of yeezy wow
so he gave her like a cut of his fashion
that whether it was easy or something
else staying loyal for staying loyal you
gave her a cut oh that's very sweet and
then like a week later i was like they
got divorced
i'm like okay what the [ __ ] is going on
they get divorced and then you see pete
davidson and uh kim kardashian on snl
right and they're kind of flirting they
have that aladdin sketch or whatever
then they then you know obviously tmz
everybody starts seeing them outside
next thing you [ __ ] know they're a
[ __ ] couple so they get divorced
kanye buys a house where right in front
of [ __ ] kid's place so he bought a
house right in front oh my gosh so he
could be close to his family but it's
literally
the house and then kanye's right there
that's kind of sadistic exactly dude you
should the post obviously he's deleted
all the posts but there was some
i feel bad because he is bipolar
but i'm still going to laugh
like i'm still going to [ __ ] laugh
part of me feels like kanye knows people
are going to laugh at this dude he was
going in on dude this is how [ __ ]
like his mental state is right so
he
got it he was posting all the texts that
he was getting from kim kardashian right
and in the post it would say it would
show the text and the text says hey
the way that you're behaving and the way
that you're treating um what's his face
pete davidson right he's going to get
seriously hurt and damaged right i saw
that screenshot and then in the caption
he goes hey leave leave skeet alone
alone or whatever right and then the
next the next text says
why do you always have to post
everything i write to you but he posted
that on instagram
and at the bottom it says because i love
you
but i think i saw another screenshot too
like about how he's gonna stop using
capital letters yeah because it sounds
like he's yelling he's like how is that
not funny
he's like i understand that a lot of
people you have misconstrued my emotions
because i write in all caps it's like
yeah no [ __ ] kanye if you're writing all
caps yeah it sounds like you're [ __ ]
yelling all the time so he's not gonna
use caps anymore and then i guess the
recent post was um
this full
ran off uh i guess pete davis is not on
instagram anymore he deleted his account
because of all like either the threats
or all the comments he was getting a lot
of comments people calling him skeet or
whatever and then obviously kanye's
[ __ ] loving it yeah but one of the
funniest posts that he puts even before
that he goes like
pete davidson texted me hey man i don't
mean any disrespect he goes i just you
know i care about your family or
whatever and you know one day i hope i
could be a healthy part of your
children's lives and he goes there's no
[ __ ] way you're gonna be a part of my
kid's life on the caption and it's a
picture of him and machine gun kelly in
their underwear
like a sketch
a dog
i know it's not supposed to be funny
because he's inadvertently funny yes
he's just inadvertently funny the way
trump is yes the [ __ ] he says is [ __ ]
up but it's like kind of funny exactly
[ __ ] up like maybe you shouldn't be
saying this but it's funny because
you're the [ __ ] president yeah
what the [ __ ] kanye is like this
multi-millionaire uh just
hyper influential guy in in the music
space
uh in fashion and everything and just to
see like
i'm not enjoying his spiral right just
because let's just put it in in this
context i am a huge kanye west fan or
was
recently it's just been a little tough
to be his family
but my friends let's continue to keep
genius brain sponsored by supporting our
podcast sponsor ipvanish i love ipvanish
and i say i love a lot of things but i
use ipvanish all the time because a lot
of people don't know for example that if
you go incognito mode on your browser it
doesn't actually protect your privacy
that's right without added security you
might as well give away all your private
data to hackers advertisers your isp and
other prying eyes even your physical
location will be hidden if you use ip
vanish and guess what the reason why i
use ipvanish because it makes it easy to
stay truly private and secure on the
internet ipvanish helps you safely
browse the internet by encrypting a
hundred percent of your data and
ipvanish is offering an incredible 70
off their yearly plan for genius brain
listeners with a 30 day money back
guarantee that's just like getting nine
months for free listen if you do not
have ipvanish hop on this stuff right
now this is an amazing deal so go to
ipvanish.com brain and use promotional
code brain and claim your 70 savings
that's ipva and i sh.com
brain
his music definitely was a big influence
in my life right
dropout college graduation
uh all that other stuff i could i could
cite lyrics for it from his stuff all
day right but
you gotta admit man from an outside
perspective though yes i do feel for him
i do feel like yeah this guy does have
you know some mental issues
stop making me laugh
i can't i can't [ __ ] help it
i can't help but [ __ ] giggle dude
i mean like
you know i i don't really follow a whole
lot on the whole uh kanye thing or even
like any kind of entertainment news i i
i stopped following that but i am way
more interested in the character of
kanye yeah the kind of person is that's
why i can't stop watching it happen it's
also because like loki he's like a
genius dude right i mean that's his
whole
career
path like no matter what he does right
he's always reinventing himself some way
or another right but if you look through
what he's done and how he's reinvented
it's constantly
making something that's not cool cool
again
or not cool again just cool right like
preppy look yeah what was his first
album called college dropout why because
it's not cool to drop out of college and
he's trying to make it cool right and
and the clothes he was wearing too right
a lot of the express men's stuff the
the the vest with the tie and all that
yeah because i specifically remember
buying collared shirts from express
because of kanye west
we're doing the double collar uh the
shirts the double collar shirts and
stuff like that the in the
the the bright pink shirts and
everything else which by the way kanye
thank you for that because
uh i wore a pink collared shirt once and
while i was getting uh [ __ ] dumped on
the phone outside of my parents house
this guy drove by and said real men wear
pink shirts [ __ ] today
as i was getting rolled up as i was as
he drove off as i was wearing this pink
collar shirt
thank you for that that was amazing but
yeah i mean like what's his next thing
after that um i mean uh he was wearing
the like futuristic shiny jackets and
all that [ __ ] in those glasses and what
the [ __ ] everyone started wearing these
glasses with bars and you can't even see
through yep right because his whole
thing was making uncool things cool and
then you keep going with the 808 and
heartbreaks like this is
mixed kind of funny yeah yeah
i don't want to say terrible because he
is a musical he knows what he's doing he
did it on purpose or all that [ __ ] i
think he was just trying to make
auto-tune in 808's cool again his thing
too is so weird because i remember
listening to 808s in heartbreak and i
didn't [ __ ] like it i didn't like it
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] yeah the next thing
you know a year later everybody's using
808 drums yes everything sounds like
that album and everything is auto-tuned
yeah and then like even far east move
and started trespassing yeah yeah yeah
yeah they had the shiny suits with the
ties and everything right he is the
influencers influencer yeah yes
and so that was his whole thing so even
when i look at his whole manga phase the
mega phase i mean like that [ __ ] was
because he was trying to make something
totally uncool cool cool but what an
interesting thing i think he failed at
that one yeah just just a little bit
yeah
and maybe perhaps what he's doing
knowing knowing
who he is because he is very much a
narcissist too yeah um
that he knows what he's doing and he
knows who he's doing it for yeah and why
he's doing it and the response he's
going to get out of it
part of me believes that and the other
part of me also believes he's off his
hinges
yeah i mean
i feel like to when we look at history
some of the most genius people they were
a little crazy oh yeah everyone that's
what i'm starting to learn more and more
so i have a friend who's hanging out
with a lot of billionaires these days
yeah are they all [ __ ] weird and nuts
they're all
high functioning autistics
yes that's
dude i just talked about this with
khalif i was like dude i don't think
i have enough like mental ailments to
make it in the city yeah
i don't think i'm like autistic enough i
don't think i have like adhd adhd to be
a successful actor or artist this crazy
weird driven
voice in your head
that's constantly screaming at you kind
of thing like like some of my friends
too who are like our friends who we look
at i'm like dude they're low-key kind of
genius they're [ __ ] psychopaths do
yes yes they don't really funk they're
not that's why like they are like
semi-aliens yeah kind of like they like
did you really come from this earth yeah
right because they're very detached from
um
i to say humanity like that's the first
word but that's not that's not the right
thing i think it's more or less the
the that they don't relate on the
regular human level yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're
i don't know if i want to say beyond it
yeah like because they're beyond like
emotions sometimes let's say like i have
this yeah high functioning autistic
friend he's the smartest person i know
on earth
but um
he he told me like oh did you see this
marvel movie this and that and he's like
yeah like he told me he saw the entire
mcu movies because everyone kept telling
him to watch it says okay i have to
watch it get into the american lexicon
right but then he explained to me that
he can't read emotions on people's faces
or their voices
he just hears the words as it is
and without emotion at all and so that's
why he a lot of times comes off as a
[ __ ] dick my dog died
and and he will have no feeling about it
it's just okay thanks for telling me
that fact i don't know like it's like
that that's so interesting it's hard to
go to him to ask for sympathy or empathy
because he actually doesn't know how
he's supposed to respond because he's
just hearing information
and it's like like if you were just a
robot
that's just you know ones and zeros okay
your dog died what about it
that's [ __ ] interesting yeah so as he
watches these movies it's just like
okay so now there's a big purple alien
okay so now there's this is the person
that i'm thinking about yes for sure see
that kind of makes sense too because
like
because of like the job that he's in and
it's like in an artistic field even the
stuff that he creates feels like that
yes it's very like
this is how it is this is how it should
be right but in the field that he's in
like when the zeros and ones don't align
it doesn't necessarily mean that things
aren't right yeah right so like for
example one of the greatest exact let's
talk about like when we talk about film
yes one of the funniest things is like
um
every film and painting i love that
right but there was just one other clip
i forgot which director it was i think
it was drive it was the breakdown of
drive yeah like the quadrants yeah and
he was talking about one specific scene
where he was like why he chose to use
the 50mm lens and the director was like
i just like the way it looks
like i don't know i don't know yeah
yeah so amanda was on set with him and
the way he explains how he looks at a
monitor
he's not exactly looking at the footage
he's looking a lot of the at the
histograms and the numbers
it's really weird he processes images
like a computer and he processes light
and how it's supposed to bend
like against all types of different
surfaces
like it's crazy like the way he looks at
cameras is not the way i look at it
that's so interesting some of my
favorite people that i know that shoot
they don't look at any of that [ __ ] they
just see i like i want it to look like
this and this is how it should look yeah
but if you ask them about the technical
aspects of what's going on i don't
[ __ ] know oh this man is all
technical and he sees a camera monitor
like the matrix code he sees numbers
like that's what's so crazy yeah thank
god he's not a [ __ ] serial killer
no
my god dude that's like that one weird
like scary part it's like i wonder
what's going to happen here right they
were talk you know what's been really i
never i only heard about it today but i
saw tweets about it it was the um
the tinder swindler or something like
that yeah
that's just been trending like crazy i
guess it's a documentary is it is it
what is it about do you know so i i
heard about him in the news i actually
don't know to be honest i don't know
that's for another episode when we
actually watched yeah we got to watch
that [ __ ] yeah people were talking about
i guess like somebody who like literally
scam people out of like millions of
dollars
so sorry so i
i
i've got i had someone trust attempted
to scam me this week dude
did you send me the yeah i did i did
okay all right so
all right we're gonna do a little role
play
so i got a series of dms this week right
and
um
basically it was a super hot girl on
this instagram page who just randomly
hit me up
and for me i'm already suspicious like
if you're this crazy hot
you know then why are you just talking
to a stranger like me you know
like that's already odd
and then that's how the basically the
conversation started going because i
questioned it i was like why why are you
talking to me because i'm way past like
just like hey what's up what did you do
today i'm like i don't know who the [ __ ]
you are
[Laughter]
so even so even daddy
[ __ ] because i was suspicious
i googled reverse
reverse image searched her her pictures
oh how the [ __ ] do you do that um you
take a screenshot but i think you can
only do it on a desktop it's hard to do
on the phone okay and so you upload the
image to google image and it'll go
through where it came from right
it was clean it was an original image
all of her pictures were original so i
was like oh [ __ ] this is a real person
right so i was like okay i'll chat i
guess but i'm still like i don't know
who the [ __ ] you are you know i don't
know why you're talking to me and then
she hits me up one night
and so
you i want you to i sent i sent david
the text okay so i got the i got the one
yeah you play this abg girl okay
do you have an accent in mind really
i mean this person is japanese
but
yeah she's half japanese half filipino
abg girl oh damn that's a
how are you doing no i don't know
what are you doing now
all right i just got home and pretty
much up to nothing lol how about you
nothing to do
alone here feeling lonely i want to have
fun now
how so
i'm just playing with myself now doing
sexy things to have fun
god damn
sounds like a lot of fun laughing face
emoji
just to kill the boredom can you help me
to have fun
do you have skype so we can do it
privately
yeah i need to download it again and
find my login okay okay tell me your
skype id alright i'll get back to you
when i find it i'll wait
before i do this i need to know you're a
real person
okay
can you send me a selfie of you with a
fork on your head
are you serious a fork no way
yeah
never mind
well your photos are super hot but i
won't participate without it i look like
a dumb person sorry i can send you a
normal photo without a fork
and then what she actually did was sent
me a pr uh one you know one of those
photos you can see once yeah and it was
a regular selfie in bed
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy my friends we have talked
about better help on this podcast
multiple times because i use it you
should use it too and i'm telling you
right now relationships take work you
know this especially the most important
one you could have in your life and
that's your relationship with yourself
and a lot of us will drop anything to go
help someone we care about well guess
what we'll even go out of our way to
treat other people well but you know how
often do we give ourselves that same
treatment and that's where better help
comes here self-care mental health
therapy all this stuff is good for you
it's helped me out a lot and i've used
better help multiple times and i got to
tell you pretty freaking awesome man
spending that time to develop the
relationship i have with myself and kind
of collect my thoughts and have somebody
there for me has been super super
beneficial i love better health better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy this podcast is sponsored by
better help and genius brain listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius but i didn't
believe it even though it was more of a
private not a professional looking shoe
yeah yeah i was like
yeah i don't think so
so i said i don't know it's really hard
to believe you're real it's okay
how about a photo of you with a shoe on
your head
sorry it's okay i don't need to prove
anything
i'll just play alone so are you a lonely
girl behind a phone or a neckbeard
behind a keyboard stop insulting me
you know bumble or hinge are pretty good
dating apps i'm a girl you can reject me
just do not insult me thank you
all right sorry i'm just trying to get
to know the real you because if you are
lonely modern dating apps are excellent
ways to meet people in your area
this podcast is brought to you by
so i send her a photo with myself with a
shoe on my head to be like look now it's
not weird anymore
so send me this photo send me this photo
and she wouldn't send it and then
immediately afterwards she deleted her
profile
wow
so i googled this [ __ ] right what kind
of person wants to skype chat yeah yeah
like instagram has live video too right
yeah so i looked up skype scams and
there was an entire article about it
what the [ __ ] is that about so
[Laughter]
whoever somebody behind a bunch of
photos of really pretty women
or whatever
use some kind of algorithm i don't know
they they search through all these
profiles right and they look for lonely
men
i was a prime candidate
that kind of that's offensive well i
mean if you look at my instagram i have
zero pictures of girls
and so
uh and i kept reading through and
they'll initially start a conversation
and um
and they'll talk like very normal people
they don't sound like robots yeah right
and so they'll say hey let's video chat
on skype
and so people will set up a skype chat
right
and then they'll they'll start chatting
with this person but the the
this girl quote-unquote
will like send you fake photos of her
boobs or a puss or some [ __ ] right and
say now you send me a photo of your dick
right send me a photo of you
masturbating or some [ __ ] i know what
this is bro right and then they [ __ ]
scammed yeah they blackmailed them to
give me thousands of dollars or i'm
gonna send this to all your friends
bro you want to hear something so
[ __ ] funny i think this happened to a
friend uh our mutual acquaintance of
ours right this happened do you know
this is a young kid
um just tell the story
i personally don't know this kid that
close but i know of of this kid right
and it's just the same thing happened
but you know and just
this kid happens to be a very lonely boy
he is a very lonely boy
he doesn't have many like sexual
interactions or if any other i think
that's a virgin that hasn't even had his
first kiss how old uh i think like in
mid-20s okay yeah and so growing growing
trend in our generation
right i mean this generation very cool
kid super dope man just the sweetest
kindest dude and that's why this happens
to him right so you know it's like hey
send me a picture of your dick blah blah
blah gets it and next thing you know
hey
i'm going to blackmail you for
everything that you have like i'm going
to send this to your family and blah
blah blah unless you send me whatever
ten thousand dollars this [ __ ]
doesn't have ten thousand dollars yeah
you know what i mean
and the funny thing about the story is
that this person is from a very very
religious household
hyper religious like missionary parents
type of religious right
starts freaking the [ __ ] out right but
because he doesn't have the money
decides to just go ahead and tell his
parents
it says i have been sending by dick pics
doesn't do the girls online and there
was a bot gets caught the parents what
they do is like we have to pray for your
sins
he said that he had to get in a prayer
circle with his parents and they had to
pray on their knees for hours
oh just because he's a lonely boy
oh that's so [ __ ] sad and this dude
is such he doesn't deserve that type of
[ __ ] man oh it feels so bad these
[ __ ] dude i would just send
them dude i would just send them like
freaking like somebody's
random that's not mine just the biggest
thing ever yeah like the most obscene
i'm gonna blackmail you good guy
please please tell everyone about my
king kong really dark complexion
penis all right
they're like did you guys know that
david is sending his ten inch dick to
everybody and everybody's like tennis
dick yeah my god
your career will shoot through the roof
i gotta look through my dms i hope this
happens that'd be hilarious i just
started like [ __ ] multi i just sent
him a picture of a vagina it's like i
actually have a vagina now you're back
to the [ __ ] bathroom situation
i knew it
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] crazy crazy it's a skype
scam yeah there's so many different dude
have you ever been a scam before no i've
been close and then i i've been
suspicious yeah i got scammed only once
and it was it was actually through
amazon before they were really secure
about this stuff but i bought a used mp3
player
and then um some of some [ __ ] didn't go
through it and then like the buyer
emailed me directly saying like hey like
your payment didn't go through but just
paid through this thing oh cool and i
sent them like 100 bucks yeah and i
never got it
and i looked at it i was like oh this is
from africa yeah this is a scam and i
just lost 100 [ __ ] dollars but once
it happens to you once you're done
you're done right yeah because i've been
close so many times that's why i was so
suspicious of this girl it's like
dude like normal people don't just hit
other people like this dude the the the
scam calls from india are so [ __ ]
funny gosh but they're so keen to it now
now that when i [ __ ] around with them i
just i block them now because now the
joke's not that funny yeah but they it's
it's weird because they sound like they
don't give a [ __ ] about scamming you
yeah they're just reading off a piece of
paper yeah
like
this is the one that i got was about
like me owing like [ __ ] like ten
thousand dollars to the irs or some [ __ ]
like that right and then if i don't pay
then i'm gonna go to jail and they're
gonna seize all my [ __ ] they're like
hello sir you are about ten thousand
dollars to irs and if you don't pay it
you're going to go to jail and i'm like
who is this like ten thousand and
they're like ten thousand dollars if you
don't we're going to seize all of your
assets and i'm like
i actually got 10 million
right
and also just 10 000 i'm like no no no i
owe 10 million and you have to kill me
to get this money back you could just
[ __ ] with him yeah they just hang up
it's better to waste their time too once
you start wasting their time then yeah
then they'll hang up on you you just
gotta do it to them i just gotta do it
longer dude but the other thing is
though if you do [ __ ] like that i feel
like they retaliate and they send more
like spam calls they put your phone
number out there to all these other
spots too oh my god well it doesn't
matter we get spam calls every day now
yeah non-stop i don't know why they
can't figure that [ __ ] out for real
we're still we're like literally right
now trying to go to mars and like why
can't you deal with this [ __ ] right yeah
i always get these random spam calls
every [ __ ] day saying that they're
gonna seize my [ __ ] that like my money's
gonna disappear dude i know one person
who got those kind of calls
and she paid up how much
i don't know she wouldn't tell me
because she was super embarrassed about
it and i knew she didn't appreciate it
when i kept joking about it
because the way they actually take
payments so you can't trace it is
through like apple gift cards
once it gets to that point you should be
like what the [ __ ] why am i paying these
debts through apple
gift cards i heard the scams work on old
people yeah so those are the people who
are the main victims or all people who
just don't know anything
they don't know the future but for any
of you guys out there uh the irs will
never ever ever ever ever contact you
through the phone yeah
you already know that the government
always likes to use [ __ ] dated paper
mail yeah that's for sure dude and then
you don't see it and it's your fault
somehow yeah so don't if you ever get
some type of important call from that
type of [ __ ] it'll never be through the
phone it'll always be through [ __ ]
snail mail or some [ __ ] like that yeah
so for all the ugly guys out there stay
skeptical yeah
there's no hot girl trying to talk to
you man there's no [ __ ] hot girl
saying that she wants to finger herself
to your [ __ ] greasy face are you
lonely guys out there no one's trying to
flick their bean dude if i got that
message like dude you're so hot i'd be
like bro you are lying yeah there's no
way even i i was like there's no [ __ ]
way this person's wants talking to me
about this [ __ ] i was like which which
which picture did you find really hot
when i was 280 pounds
like which one i also did get another
[ __ ] dm
um
this person wanted me to do some voice
over work
i sent you that so here's the thing we
can't i don't think we can really talk
about what was in there because you
might get cancelled
well i'll get canceled because it's not
like i'm i'm doing anything with it but
it's the request was so
[ __ ] weird i mean i feel
look
lonely guys out there when someone gives
you attention any dude understands like
oh [ __ ] attention yeah i'm a girl yeah
yeah like yeah what's up what's going on
um
but they wanted me to read some not safe
for work content as voice over really
inappropriate not safe for work content
yeah and i wasn't comfortable with it
and this was something i've never done
before
but i didn't want to be rude about it
and also apparently like king shaming is
a really bad thing too
oh
i guess what everybody can to some
degree but i just had to say
uh yeah not my not my thing sorry um
and i didn't know how to continue it
either
because like
when you when you shoot for the moon
it's like i don't know how to back up
with this and also just like i'll just
be
appropriate in a normal me
they really like your regular speaking
voice like dude i want him to say some
of this dirty disgusting filthy go to
jail type of [ __ ] it was go to jail kind
it was straight up like can blackmail me
can ruin my life kind of stuff yeah it's
i'm like although it's fantasy
i don't think i should be saying this
dude people got [ __ ] mad at me years
ago i think that my still might be a
reddit thread about this but then i um
i i kind of said that you know people
who like fanfic stuff i thought i was
like isn't that stuff all like weird
sexual [ __ ]
bro the [ __ ] was like it's not
only about sex
it's about just other scenarios
which i assume that's what you sound
like you [ __ ] weirdo i don't know you
know i mean i don't know
everybody thinks that they're an
oppressed group now it's like if we
don't agree with like you don't agree
with my effective lifestyle you're not
an oppressed group there's no rights
being taken away from you right there's
there's no like government oppression
nobody's taking your wages nobody's
ostracizing you in that type of way you
just you just like some weird [ __ ]
that's all that it is you're not an
oppressor that's what
i suppose that people don't understand
like years ago i made this joke
i said you know greasy gamer and the
gaming community oh [ __ ] flipped the
[ __ ] out and this is from a guy that
used to play a lot of games yeah and
like you do know i look like you
what are you talking about
what the [ __ ] and they're like you think
all [ __ ] gamers are just greasy
[ __ ] losers i was like you said
losers
[Laughter]
what are you getting at i mean that's
the thing like you can make fun of
everybody else just not me yeah you know
that's one of those [ __ ] and it was
like you don't know what we went through
i was like okay now this conversation is
going through something else you don't
know how long we have to wait for gta 6
okay and then also i started seeing a
[ __ ] like uh spiritual [ __ ]
wait in the water
i'm like we need a revolt yeah it's like
relax dude all right just [ __ ] relax
you're playing games you're having a
good time it was just a little [ __ ]
joke all right you're completely okay
with us making fun of like all this
other stuff but all of a sudden like
you're the oppressed gaming group like
even my friends were gamers like what
the [ __ ] are these guys talking about
like chill i think when like i mean like
i can almost really because i don't say
like controversial [ __ ] but then like i
get fact checked a lot in the
comments so i say one thing about the
about ned and spider-man being almost 30
and he's not he's actually 26 guys and
that was all right one thing i remember
just getting [ __ ] on for was like okay
cool hey i tell people to fact check me
all the time i say pure nonsense 24 7.
yeah like i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about i think trying to pull up
your phone like we just did earlier kind
of wastes a lot of time if you want like
you know what david before we say this
let me look at my phone let me google
this before this and by the way we don't
we don't have anybody to do this stuff
for us
i think that's the biggest difference is
that i think for those type of you don't
have a jamie yeah guy behind there where
you like jamie look this up real quick
and there's also no reason to like like
a small detail like that who cares right
right 25 30 who cares whatever it's like
a small side comment i was like talking
about matrix for like 40 minutes
straight
dude you blew people's [ __ ] minds
with that one dude they were like what
the [ __ ] i need to re-watch this whole
series but ned isn't 30 years old yeah
how [ __ ] dare you but i'm glad i'm
glad a lot like i love doing the the
movie reviews here it helps me get a lot
of [ __ ] off my chest because i used to
do all these movie reviews on facebook
right because like those are my because
i was on facebook since 07 you know when
it was like first new to like a lot of
just random people not just college
students
and so a lot of my facebook friends are
actually people i personally know yeah
yeah and so i used to write these long
[ __ ] essays about my movie reviews
and like the way i thought about a movie
and then realizing dude i need to go to
sleep
i need to stop
like obsessing over this thought it's
also a lot easier to tell somebody yeah
than it is to write it all out write it
all down it's way more interesting when
there's banter because i care so much
about my written grammar and i don't
give a [ __ ] about how i talk
yeah so yeah when i s saying all that
[ __ ] is so much easier than writing it
down so i just that's why i'm so
grateful to come here and just talk
about movies you know what the podcast
is really good for the podcast is really
good for listening back to the way that
you speak and realize that you just make
up a bunch of words that don't exist
yeah i'm like dude you're actually not
that great in english david oh yeah
you're terrible i suck my filler words
are like
so going around in circles it doesn't
ever make sense yeah well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast you can catch ed at ed
park vp geniusbrains every sundays and
make sure that when you're on like
itunes spotify whatever give us a thumbs
up share the podcasts out there if
you're laughing having a good [ __ ]
time that means somebody else will too
every sundays 12 p.m i love this podcast
always super fun and if you want
celebrities to be on here probably
[ __ ] not
[Laughter]
see y'all next time peace peace